[Music]
if you were born on the same year that
Shenmue 2 is released you're now able to
vote by fireworks and get a tattoo
without asking for your parents
permission for series devotees it's been
18 long years of waiting to find out
where ryo hazuki's quest to avenge his
murdered father will lead him next and
at long last we're going to get some
answers and probably a lot of new
questions - the road to Shenmue 3 has
been long and challenging them with
legendary game designer Yu Suzuki
ultimately turning to fans for help in
making the latest chapter in his
incredibly ambitious saga a reality
nearly 70,000 people donated over 6
million dollars to the project back in
2015 that's the power of a cliffhanger
approaching adulthood people
[Music]
the first Shenmue is regarded as one of
the original open-world adventures a
game that paved the way for some of the
Titans of the genre that dominate the
charts today naturally there have been
concerns that Shenmue 3 would seek to
take cues from contemporary open-world
games and lose some of its idiosyncratic
charm in the process not so this is as
deliberately paced and packed with
delightful little details as fans expect
as Ryo takes his first steps through the
rural Chinese village of Bai Luo it's
immediately apparent that this is a game
that wants you to take your time and
soak up the atmosphere and after an
18-year wait
it seems rude not to
[Music]
you Suzuki and his talented team haven't
lost a beat when it comes to creating
worlds that feel authentic organic and
lived in on the outskirts of bailu a
gentle babbling stream flows through
rolling fields teeming with flowers
trees and rocky outcrops the village
itself is perfectly imperfect signs a
cracked and warm with age the corrugated
iron roof tops of weathered scratched
and dented vegetable patches are
abundant with crops and street stalls
are packed with enticing foods and
intriguing curios there's an admirable
level of craft on display here that
warrants pouring over every square inch
as fans are well aware Rio is not afraid
of striking up a conversation with
anyone who cares to listen which in
shenmue's case is practically everyone
the NPC's of Shenmue 3 are many and
memorable from scrappy little kids with
a pawn shop the Tai Chi to craggy old
kung fu masters with lustrous white
eyebrows
unlike the environments the character
art style veers away from photo realism
and steers closer to caricature allowing
for a welcomed diversity of faces and
body types somewhat ironically this
serves to contribute to the overall air
of authenticity honestly I don't think
your kung fu is strong enough
although he's been studying martial arts
since he was seven Rio still has plenty
to learn and China has a lot to teach
him by visiting various schools and
encountering masters you're able to pick
up and develop a range of new techniques
sometimes you'll simply be perfecting
your Bruce Lee style one-inch punch
against the wooden training dummy but
often you'll be trying to land moves on
human opposition in a bid to improve
their efficacy and upgrade Rio's core
skills all that training is intended to
get Rio ready for the real world where
enemies and disciples of his archrival
landy on lining up to bruise that pretty
face of his Shenmue threes combat is
rebuilt from the ground up
but the influence from you Suzuki's
previous work is still evident and not
necessarily limited to his experience in
fighting games in a sly nod to the
racing franchise that first drew suzuki
to the world's attention players can
choose between automatic transmission
and manual transmission the former
automates combo strings for the benefits
of players who are more concerned with
enjoying the story while manual leaves
everything in your hands Rio will pick
up a number of new styles to sit
alongside the moves he picks up in the
previous two games and will have to make
strategic use of everything in his
arsenal to counter his rivals deadly
techniques
and finally Shenmue 3 couldn't call
itself a Shenmue game if it wasn't
filled with engrossing minigames and
compelling diversions all designed to
distract Ryo from his grand quest this
it knows all too well as within minutes
of entering bilú Ryo will happen upon
his first capsule toy machines a true
Shenmue signature soon after he's
goading into gambling away what little
he has on dice vintage pachinko boards
and even turtle races as he continues to
explore you'll also discover some
incredibly retro arcade games including
the returning reflex testing favourite
QTE title you can experience the
long-awaited third chapter of Ryo
hazuki's quest for vengeance when
Shenmue 3 releases on PlayStation 4 and
the epic game store on November 19
[Music]